presidents governor's briefing on covin
19 on June 29th so you've heard from him
recently along with the rest of our
doctors in the past five days dr. Hahn's
been on TV six times as well the
president has confidence confidence in
the conclusions of our medical experts
but it's up to him to determine what to
do with that information and to take
what we hear from dr. Fouts you dr.
Burks and others and take away key
values in their opinion and come to the
ultimate consensus that's best for this
country well what what is it exactly in
the CDC guidelines that the president
doesn't like yeah so the CDC guidelines
that the president mentioned today I
would note that it was emphasized by dr.
Redfield that he doesn't want these
guidelines to be a reason for schools to
not reopen they're not requirements and
they're not prescriptive and that's per
the CDC director what is it that the
president thinks is too strict and too
expensive and too impractical as I think
one of the things is in the guidelines
which I would note that in these
guidelines there are 28 implicit
acknowledgments that these guidelines
aren't even feasible and 18 times it's
mentioned that some of this might not be
possible and nine times it's mentioned
that some of this might not be feasible
so that's embedded into the guidelines
in one specific example I'll give you is
on food services have children bring
their own meals as feasible
well there are 22 million children in
this country who depend on these meals
at schools who depend on access to
nutrition in schools that's one example
there there are several that are in
there but we need to make sure as the
American we're gonna change is my point
well you'll see because as the vice
president said the CDC will come out
with new guidelines additional
guidelines there will be I think five he
said and you'll see those when they come
up in question just really quickly as
the president and the CDC clearly don't
seem to be on the same page on what the
guidance is what he is hoping they put
out with CDC CDC is actually putting out
so why isn't the president just go to
these task force meetings so then he can
talk about with them because our
reporting is that he hasn't got the one
since April so I would note that the CDC
is very much on the same page as the
president which is why you heard the CDC
director today underscore these are not
prescriptive these are not requirements
and that there will be supplemental
guidelines so they are on the same page
the president's routinely briefed about
the coronavirus each and every day the
relevant information is brought to him
on the big decisions and then he moves
forward and the way that's best for our
country Joe Joe Haley is following up on
those new CDC guidelines that we're told
are coming out next week did the White
House pressure of the CDC to change
public health guidelines that were
reached in accordance with medical
professionals because the president
doesn't like them no not at all but the
president made his opinion quite clear
publicly this morning on Twitter for all
to see and we would note that guidelines
and I would underscore the American
Academy of Pediatrics because it is an
organization that's made up of 67,000
pediatricians that they represent
they're very adamant about kids needing
to go back to school and they said
school policies must be flexible and
nimble and responding to new information
and administrators must be willing to
refine approaches when specific policies
are not working policy should be
practical feasible and appropriate for
child and adolescent development stage
against social distancing guidelines and
school things that are included in those
guidelines now like placing desks apart
from each other
staggering a school times those elements
of it so I'm not going to get into each
and every element and where he stands on
it the president wants us to go back to
school safely our children depend on it
these schools are essential and I think
he stands on the side of parents across
this country who want to see their kids
back in the school who want to see make
sure that their kids don't fall behind
in education yes Christine Bailey by
this point in the 2016 campaign
President Trump had been talking about
what would ultimately become the u.s.
MCA for more than nine months so when do
you think we can expect president Trump
to detail his priorities for a second
term I think you hear him talk about it
quite often more trade deals are on the
horizon from this president lower taxes
more funding for our schools one
announcement that I do have for you is
that and Kerr's act for he's looking to
substantially bump up money for
education but at the same time
understand that this money should go to
students so that's one priority we're
looking at more in the immediate term
support
schools supporting our families he's
talked about pay out stimulus payouts to
Americans that worked very well the
first time it's something he's mentioned
for a phase four he's talked about
payroll tax holiday which would be a big
tax break for America's workers so those
are a few and me immediate term and
you'll be hearing a lot more about a
second term in the coming months
he might detail some of those priorities
in his speech this Saturday at the rally
in New Hampshire so I don't want to get
ahead of his speech this Saturday but
you'll certainly be hearing incoming
speeches more about the president's
vision for the second term building the
economy is one thing that he mentioned
just this week you know he brought
hottest economy in modern history once
he wants to do it again he did that
through deregulation through lower taxes
and that led to historic low
unemployment for black Americans
Hispanic Americans disabled our veterans
and those are the kind of policies
conservative policies he's looking at
for a second term and anything that you
could say to Republicans on Capitol Hill
who have talked to reporters and said
that they would like President Trump to
perhaps be a bit more forceful about
what exactly he would intend to do well
the president's been very clear I mean I
just mentioned to you what he wants and
cares Act four he's mentioned some other
things so I think he's very vocal about
what he wants and you'll be hearing more
from him Justin just following the rally
question just before you came out the
director of the Tulsa Health Department
said that the president's rally very
likely contributed to a surge in chronic
virus cases in the city we know that al
as an advisor to the president also have
tested positive since Tulsa and in New
Hampshire masks are recommended but not
required so I'm wondering first why the
president continues not to require masks
of those rallies considering we've seen
the public health outcomes that come
from it whether that that or other
changes or something the president's
been operating in accordance with CDC
guidelines recommended but not required
but as he said recently if you weren't
tested every day and he was in a
situation where he couldn't distance he
would wear masks we hand them out
they're handed out by the campaign
rather at these events on and there's
ample hand sanitizer and it's people's
individual choice as to whether to to go
director sir I would I would just say I
have no data to indicate that on my end
but it's the decision of individuals
whether to go we encourage the wearing
of mass was the president said if he
couldn't distance he would but it's the
individual choice of the person the
chief staff National Security Advisor
who talks in the last couple days
indicating that the president might both
signed the bill that was passed by
Congress earlier last week and
additional action someone or in both
that you have any updated guidance on
the timing of those things but also
we've heard concerned from US companies
that sort of aggressive sanctions that
would be unlocked under the latest bill
could hurt their businesses in Hong Kong
and China and so I'm wondering if you
could kind of talk through the
administration's thoughts about
balancing you know how oppressively you
a section in Chinese officials versus US
business interests so I'm not gonna get
ahead of the President on what our
actions on China will be but you will be
hearing about some upcoming actions that
pertain to China so I can confirm that
yes thank you Katie so still on Hong
Kong this morning Robert O'Brien said
that China has basically annexed home
home can you see what he means by that
and what the administration plans to do
about it I think his words are quite
clear we've been quite clear from this
podium that Hong Kong special status is
at risk because of the Chinese actions
just to follow up on annexation what are
the administration's plans on actual
plans for all annexation from the
Israeli on parts of the West Bank so I
won't get ahead of the President
on those actions yes this morning take
funding away first of all what why would
he want to take funding away from
schools to the second of all which
funding is he referring to specifically
and thirdly what authority does he have
to do that given that most public
schools are funded by local property
taxes so I would note that what I said -
Kristen just a bit ago he wants to
increase funding and cares for for
education but he's looking at
potentially redirecting that to make
sure it goes to the student and it is
most likely tied to the student and not
to a district where
are closed and I would note that he said
this is something he may consider in the
tweet I heard what she said
with regard to cares but with which
regarding to the president he was saying
it as a I guess a threat if Democratic
governors or officials don't open
schools in the way that he wants them
I'm just wondering again what authority
he would use to do that in which
specific ones he's targeted yeah not in
the ways that he want them to open he
wants them to reopen altogether he wants
students to be welcome back to these
schools because there are real
consequences let's be clear about what
we're talking about here we're talking
about a situation where you have the
American Academy of Pediatrics talking
about the negative impacts of children
not in schools learning deficits is
among them
there's increases in child and
adolescent physical or sexual abuse
because you don't have people reporting
and notifying like teachers and PE
teachers and school personnel notifying
health department's when they see signs
of this you have increased substance
abuse depression and suicidal ideation
and this is from the American Academy of
Pediatrics of the president he's going
to push schools to reopen these are
grave consequences even CNN reporting
that experts believe that the recent
decline in calls to child abuse and
neglect hotlines might really mean more
cases are going on notice this is
unacceptable and our schools are
essential and our teachers are essential
workers and he wants them to open and
that's why he's speaking out so strongly
about this Haley that the schools and
the districts that are looking at this
want to do it in a safest way possible
and that's why there seems to be some
disagreement the president will always
stand up to teachers unions who want to
keep these schools closed because what
is best for the child is for these
schools to be open that is pretty clear
evany want to keep the schools close
evany pulling on from Jeff's quest
question New York City officials today
said that schools would go back in the
fall and studied scheduled up to three
days a week I'm wondering if that's
something that the administration so I
haven't spoken to him about that plan in
particular but it's encouraging anytime
you see that some kids will be welcomed
back onto the campus haven't spoken to
him specifically about the New York
scenario
the Supreme Court is expected to rule
tomorrow on whether or not the president
can keep his financial records secret
I'm wondering if the court rules against
the president we will be happy to hand
over his records to Congress and the
Manhattan district attorney
so that's hypothetical I won't answer
that and I'll wait to get back with you
guys tomorrow after we see that ruling
which we hope is in the favor of the
president yes yes so questions for you
Haley thank you
did the president ask the President of
Mexico if you would pay for the wall and
what happened to that threat so that
discussion did not come up when I was in
the room question is the president still
file that filing documents this week to
be able to resign that once again and
start the legal process no announcements
on that front but when we have it
announced then you'll be the first to
know so in the discussions I was a part
of there is not an executive order
discussed but there will be some
executive orders this week you look what
they might entail no preview but there
will be something this week and his non
appearance today
well Canada was unable to travel because
of the restrictions they have in their
country with regard to COBIT yes I know
I wanted to ask you to confirm if
President Trump and President Assad or
talked about immigration at all it came
up briefly and just noting the great
cooperation that has been had between
Mexico and the United States Mexico
mobilizing those troops to the border
when a very long way president over
towards been a great partner to this
country both on the US MCA and with
regard to immigration and with regard to
drug interdiction a lot of lives have
been saved thanks to President Trump and
president over doors cooperation yes he
knew that President Trump past
presidents Bobby Salvador
but to do an integration so I won't get
into their private details in private
conversations other than to note that
there's been great cooperation and that
was noted today
yeah yes thank you two questions
following up on Jeff's question you have
from behind the podium talk about the
importance of federalism local and state
officials being able to decide what to
do with their own residents how come
when it comes to school as a present and
this threatening school saying that if
they all follow his guidance in terms of
what they should do and reopening that
he's going to threaten their funding why
is that not that federalism principle
not main cause he thinks that funding
should go to the child it should be
there for children who are going to
school keeping schools closed down is an
untenable prospect and if this
administration is going to stand for
anything it's going to be standing
against child abuse which reporting
Falls when schools are closed it's going
to be standing for educational equality
because as noted by McKenzie and company
I was reading some very detailed studies
today that learning loss will probably
be greatest if stools if schools stay
closed among low-income black and
Hispanic students this president fights
for school choice he fights for
opportunity and he'll fight for schools
to stay open because those
disproportionately impacted are minority
communities high school dropout rates
that's another thing we know that in the
wake of school closures after Hurricane
Katrina and hurricane Maria 14 to 20
percent of students never return to
school and there's an estimate that two
to nine percent of high school students
could drop out as a result of a
permanent shutdown in schools our
schools are important they have to stay
open they are essential and the
president will stand on the side of our
children you know they're saying if you
come to America you should assimilate
why do we need to have Little Havana
that's my statement that this
administration this White House behind
so I spoke to Katie before coming out
here and she says that her those quotes
are not true as described in the book
and I'll tell you this that there is no
greater ally of the Cuban community than
President Trump he loves the Cuban
community he's moved his residents down
to Florida South Florida in particular
and he there's no greater advocate
against socialism than the Cuban
community in this country
this president who said America will
never be a socialist country yes thank
you so the city of Houston just a little
while ago canceled
the Texas Republican convention because
it concerns are there any fresh thoughts
about scaling back Jackson don't know
we're still moving forward with
Jacksonville um it'll be a safe event it
will be a good event and it will be up
to the RNC as how those details are
hashed out education a question not
lower school but colleges and
universities a couple of them at least
or challenging the ice ruling having to
do it visas for foreign students when
the universities are not holding
in-person classes and I'm wondering if
that is aimed at pressuring colleges to
fully open that feel maybe that it's not
safe to do so
I think the policy speaks for itself you
know you don't get a visa for taking
online classes from let's say University
of Phoenix so why would you if you were
just taking online classes generally and
I would note with regard to Harvard and
I MIT suing over this and all due
respect to my former alma mater perhaps
the better lawsuit would be coming from
students who have to pay full tuition
with no access to in-person classes to
attend yes flexibility with the
Jacksonville event but that flexibility
include moving events elsewhere if the
case accounts continue to rise in
Florida even possibly back to Charlotte
if the cases stabilized there go down
you know I leave that to the president
and non gaging hypotheticals but he's
very excited to go to Florida it's his
home state Jacksonville is the
designation and the designated place of
the Republican National Convention
consider how to proceed forward is as
schools are potentially considering
perhaps a middle-of-the-road approach
that for example New York is looking at
is that something that is acceptable to
the president this half half home half
of it happened the building as opposed
to opening them up fully I'll leave that
to the president
I haven't spoken to him specifically
about the middle-of-the-road approach
but I will talk to him about that and
get an answer for you one thing I want
to leave you with and thank you all
these were very good and very thoughtful
questions so I appreciated them this is
a bit of a news item
the Kansas City mayor and the in the
governor wrote to the governor rather a
letter that said this we are at a crisis
point he said an additional help was
needed to provide more tools for law
enforcement and prosecutors to interrupt
conspiracies to commit murder and the
violent acts particularly offenses
committed by felons using deadly weapons
in the streets of Kansas City I mean as
of yesterday Kansas City had reached 100
homicides a 40 percent increase from
last year according to the mayor's
office on absolutely tragic numbers and
attorney general bar is has announced
that the launch there will be a launch
of what's going to be called operation
legend it's a new initiative designated
to fight the surge of violent crime that
we've seen in Kansas City directly in
response to those requests by the mayor
and by the governor and specifically
operation legends going to focus on a
federal effort to increase law
enforcement presence in the city
attorney general Barr has directed
agents from the Department of Justice's
law enforcement agencies the FBI u.s.
marshal DEA and ATF to be on the ground
in Kansas City within the next 10 days
to help state and
you
local officials fight the surge a
violent crime operation legend is named
after four year old legend Tala Pharaoh
who tragically died on June 29th as a
result of being shot in the face while
he slept in his home Tala Pharaohs
survived a heart surgery as an infant
and he tragically lost his life and we
at the federal government want to make
sure that that never happens and use our
resources to the fullest extent of the
law to ensure that individuals and young
children like Legend are able to live
their lives and live so peacefully thank
you so much
[Music]